all right miss rita
welcome back again yes for sure for sure
how are you i'm feeling great well
you've had some interesting things
happen in your life right yes i have you
uh you now have housing for sure like
nice housing not just beautiful
sanitized
and clean yeah because you were you know
i was paying your rent at the ellis
hotel but that was just a very tiny
little room yes now you have your own
bathroom you have your own kitchen you
have a living room you have
a big apartment right yes thankful to
god in you mark and nowhere near skid
row that's nowhere near scary
and very healthy and clean environment
and you told me you put on some weight
since you've been here right yes i did
i'm getting off of drugs
and i'm trying to go for my goal and my
dream of being something that somebody
which is to become a singer you want to
be a singer
yes
very impressive very
i mean
positive towards the goal
thanks to mark
how many how many years you've been
doing
how many years you've been on skid row
i've been on skid row like
going on
19 years 19 years
about 20 years do you miss it at all no
i don't
i don't
it's really more trauma
than you know and
paid
than anything uh the area i just moved
into
it's a lot of love respect and what i'm
used to
to help me go for my great dream it's
nice to have your own
place place and private
mainly it's health
you know ain't got to get bit by red but
yeah yeah you gotta fit for him
yeah your last place yeah
as i'm to say mark's a very good person
for those i want to uh expire to
to know he do help us and we want to
reach a goal he's there for
um from supplies
you were easy to help
yeah and yeah as far as the donations
and crowds that ain't all that matters
what matters is the coming to make me
feel like somebody when i met him i was
all bad to everybody
but to know
keep pushing my goal up till i have
somebody and yeah i'm sure you had help
from your social worker and yeah my
social worker
and a few other people health
doctor
and
quite a few people but my main pusher
was mark
that's funny um
so
like food and things like that yes
you have enough money for that now yes
sir
you get money from where do you get
money from i'll be getting food stamps
on 18.
from uh gr
that's enough to get you food i'll be
getting food stamps yes i will
they they came today
excellent
so what to what what did you your 19
years here on skid row teach you
i was on ski road
me and my friend he's caucasian
better yet stepfather kid's dad we met
at a truck stop and then his name is
rick
and we rode the road on the road i got
on drugs riding with him and i couldn't
ride with him no more
we stayed in big bear and then he
traveled over this way
and i ended up staying in l.a
and because i couldn't ride with him on
the road and got more heavy on drugs
started being on the streets
and
a lot of drugs down here
yeah
none
in big bear it's a real life
and so what did your years here teach
you
huh what did you learn from being on
skid row all these years well i learned
i learned to be
there's no respect i learned there's
no heart no respect no heart
you know it's like everybody for
and
man is a lot of violence
violence a lot of violence what matters
it's very hard to be a woman down here
right yes very hard
to be a human period
from sex to drugs it's hard to be a
human
a lot of
just
scandalous behavior down here and that
yes a whole lot especially at night but
definitely
definitely
bad i used to stand in the door in my
old place
and don't come out at night
well rita i'm so glad you're you're
doing better and you're happy yes
you deserve it as much as anybody i know
yeah
thank you very much you even deserve
better mark because you have done a lot
in my life you really have that sweet
i'm not going to put a lot of smiles on
my face
you really have
i came here i was
feeling like i was on my dead last bit
of death
why because i didn't have nobody why
because i feel like germs to everybody
but now that i don't only fit in
i'm over you know yeah i mean at one
point you were homeless you were working
as a prostitute yeah
were you doing drugs back then too yeah
yeah
what did i mean you were even getting
treated really badly yeah real bad from
everyone like you go to the seating and
everything now they said money i yeah
it's a lot bad things i had to accept
to make it through that night
that i had to do to make it through the
night i'm so glad you didn't get nothing
so yeah so glad you found a better
better home for yourself and yeah a
better life and i sleep like a baby
that's in my place that's important yeah
for sure
yeah
all right well maybe maybe you'd like to
sing for us a little bit yes sure can
you sing something i would like to yeah
what do you want to sing for all right
let me see because if i don't ask no
everyone's going to give me but natalie
cole original i'm catching hell yeah
okay do i start yeah i'm ready for it
because it's on google youtube but do i
start yes go ahead
i'm catching hell
living
here alone
[Music]
i can't believe
all the pressure on me
hold me down
hold me down
[Music]
to go out of my mind
okay just go all the way
sounds great yeah
yeah thank you so much rita thank you
you're welcome it could be better if i
had the record you're gonna be scared
yeah
it's very pretty thank you very much
thanks to y'all i was thinking about
that looking at you on tv